each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
and together with my colleague Mike sis
Kowski will be joining me on stage for
the second part of the talk we'd like to
tell you a bit about the Microsoft
biology foundation so the title for this
talk is an open source library for
bioinformatics we didn't want to call it
as you'll see it's titled in the in the
program which is the Microsoft biology
foundation because we're going to change
the name so everything you hear about
the Microsoft biology foundation today
from July will be called bio decks so
and there's reasons for that which I'll
explain as part of the talk so anyway
what I'm going to tell you about in my
half of the talk is I'm going to give
you a little bit of information about
the microsoft research connections team
I won't duplicate too much the
information you heard from my colleague
Lee earlier we should probably sink on
our slides next time but I'm going to
tell you a little bit about the reason
why we exist and the way in which we
work and then I'll move on to describe
how the Microsoft biology foundation is
an example of that way of working and
I'll give you some information about mbf
itself now I don't plan to dive deeply
into the code on Monday and Tuesday this
week we actually held a workshop
training some people some of you are in
this room today on how to use mbf to do
programming but what we'll do is we'll
cover it at a higher level now all of
the tutorial materials were delivered it
earlier this week are available online
and i'll give you some links to those if
you're interested and weren't able to
make the course so the microsoft
research connections team we're spread
around the world we're located in all of
the different microsoft research labs
around the world so there's a group in
india a group in beijing group in
australia there's even a small group
here in latin america also europe and of
course in redmond
in the United States not only we
distributed around the world we're
distributed around the different types
of science that we believe Microsoft
Research can assist in in terms of the
types of technology we can bring to bear
to make that science move further and
faster than it could have without the
assistance of Microsoft those areas are
natural user interfaces of energy in the
environment health and well-being
computer science and and my area I'm
sorry in lees area education and
scholarly communication now in each one
of those areas we work essentially in
two different ways one is that we
establish collaborations between
Microsoft and between academic
researchers those collaborations all
take the same essential form which is
Microsoft brings the computer science
expertise and the academic brings the
expertise of their particular area of
research and together we try and do
something by applying the computing to
that area which could not be done before
now those collaborations are very hard
to create because Microsoft researchers
work in with many different people and
it's sometimes hard to make those
connections but when we succeed in
making one of those connections
sometimes the results are surprising and
I'll give you some examples in a moment
the other way that we work is we
generate software now you saw plenty of
examples actually from Lee and you'll
see another example in terms of the
Microsoft biology foundation from me
today so I'll just move on and I'll show
you well the areas that we work in here
now this is within a health and
well-being and essentially what we do is
we we think of the whole portfolio of
collaborations that we offer is falling
into four main areas the first one is
what we call devices sensors and
mobility and you've heard a bit about
that actually if you attended kristin
tolls natural user interfaces talk this
morning because the two areas overlap
it's the idea that most people have a
cell phone these days and those cell
phones can have tremendous capabilities
they have high-quality screens naturally
enough they're always connected to a
network
because there are cellphone at least
they should always be connected to a
network they have good computing
processing power lots of memory
considerable graphics capabilities
they're far more than just required to
you know talk to somebody as you would
use a telephone now if you imagine those
capabilities combined with increasing
bandwidth and high availability of
networks and you apply the combat
combination of those technologies into
other areas you realize that this can
become a tool for science or a tool for
health care and so there are plenty of
projects going on which just to pick one
example David's are at washington
university in st. louis missouri he
built a device which is an ultrasound
probe and the ultrasound probe probe
actually plugs into a cell phone so now
what you have is you have an ultrasound
device where you can scan someone with
the the probe say a pregnant woman to
look at the the development of the baby
and you can see the pictures on the cell
phone directly so now instead of
requiring a complex portable system that
might require an expert to use it you
can actually provide this to healthcare
workers out in the field in areas where
healthcare was not cost-effective to
provide before because those images when
they're on a cell phone they can be
transmitted to a central location where
an expert can analyze those images and
transmit the results back so the person
wielding the ultrasound probe doesn't
need to be an expert in what they're
doing and this can be cheap so all of a
sudden we have a way of scaling
healthcare into regions that didn't have
the ability to do it before now I just
give one example here are there many
other examples many other types of
device you can extend a cell phone with
or many other capabilities that a cell
phone has that you can use to deliver
health care or do health care research
around the world so that's one area
genomics in healthcare is a second area
the idea that even now the human genome
was developers for instead o when it
took over a billion dollars and it took
somewhere between five and ten years
depending on where you think the project
actually started
these days however it takes less than
five thousand dollars and less than a
week to sequence a human genome so the
technology that advanced hugely and it
hasn't stopped there are increasingly
large data sizes generated from machines
with increasingly high capacity and I
believe that within five years most
people will be able to have their genome
sequence for less than a thousand
dollars at which point at least in the
United States it becomes quite
cost-effective to sequence everybody who
who has a any sort of healthcare
coverage which means that the amount of
data will be huge and the requirement to
understand exactly what that DNA is
telling you greatly increases so that's
another area and we're interested in the
computational challenges around that
medical imaging is a third area we're
just starting to develop into this area
but we have a range of Microsoft
technologies which can take standard
medical imaging like CT scans and
automatically identify the organs that
are represented on those scans the state
of the art today is that somebody has to
actually look at these scans that a
human has to interpret what that scan is
you know what organs are represented on
that scan we have ways of automating
that process and we're starting to apply
it now to things like screening people
for colon cancer or to determining how
effectively an anti-cancer drug works by
being able to scan a person's body
automatically detect all the tumors in
that body and look at how much they're
shrinking in a very accurate manner to
determine how effective a particular
regime of drug therapy is for that
patient so we're starting to push the
boundaries in that we won't have any
solid results from one or two years
because research takes time as you all
know the last area of modeling living
systems really is a combination of
computer science and biological science
biological systems are complicated
networks of interactions between genes
and proteins RNA and DNA and computers
also a dynamic systems and there are
many different mathematical form
formalisms for modeling the performance
of programs in computers and of course
Microsoft is very familiar with these
you can take those same formalism such
as lambda calculus and apply them to
modeling a dynamic biological system
with the eventual aim of building
predictive models so you could do things
for example like create an in silico
model of a ver cancer tumor treat it in
silico with drugs and determine which
drugs are the most effective treatments
for that cancer without doing any
Studies on a patient and of course doing
it in a few minutes or a few seconds
rather than taking months to years and
having all the ethical issues of testing
those same drugs on patients i should
say we are many years away from their
eventual goal but we are starting to
build dynamic models of biological
systems then looking at the issues of
composing those models to build entire
organs or even entire organisms inside a
computer that works typically done in
microsoft research cambridge but also in
collaboration with cosby which is the
Microsoft Research University of Toronto
Centre for synthetic and systems biology
so those are the different areas that we
work in and in each one of those areas
we create these software projects that I
described when we create these
collaborations that I described let me
give you an example of how one of the
collaborations works now actually
although I've put up a slide here
talking about the electronic contact
lens I'll only touch on it briefly
because it was mentioned by Kristin toll
earlier today in the natural user
interfaces natural user interaction
session essentially what we did with
this is desney tan as a researcher in
Microsoft he's very interested in
human-computer interaction you know how
you improve a computer so that you can
interact with it in a in a simpler way
with less less constraints on the way
you can you can interact so you can be
more expressive in in working with a
computer so a computer might not look
like the laptop I have in front of me a
computer could be built into this room a
computer could be anything now there's
another group in the University of
Washington which is also based in
Seattle so it's just down the road for
us and they're very good at micro
fabrication
good at taking micro electronics and
embedding them into unusual devices what
they wanted to do if they wanted to
build a contact lens okay and in fact
they did and you can see it over there
and if you have very good eyesight you
can actually see that there are micro
electronics built into that contact lens
it's a soft contact lens you can wear it
like any other lens however the surface
of the eye is covered with a liquid and
that liquid contains about ten percent
of the the sugar level that is typical
in your blood so if you can watch how
the blood sugar varies in the fluid on
the eye you can also know how blood
sugar varies inside the body and of
course if you're diabetic that's a very
important thing to know now it'd be
lovely if you could actually trace how
your blood sugar varied through the day
if you were diabetic without having to
prick your fingers and take blood and
this could be done with this contact
lens simply what you do with the contact
lenses you build a little glucose sensor
into the contact lens so you build some
control circuits you include a way of
getting power to the contact lens which
it can be powered by radio waves and you
also put a little LED a little light or
on the contact lens and perhaps that
light turns green if your blood sugar is
okay and it turns red if your blood
sugar goes out of the normal range and
of course at first you'll notice this
because it will be a light flashing in
your eye but you know over time it's
pretty it's pretty easy you you end up
integrating these things into your
natural senses so I mean I wear glasses
I don't think about my glasses at all
anymore and the people in the audience
who are wearing glasses today they don't
think about their glasses until I talk
about it same with the contact lens so
after a while what happens is that you
don't see the red light not consciously
you just go and eat some chocolate
because you're kind of feeling like your
blood sugar is low and but it's actually
a sense that's being fed to you from you
from your eyeball so from Microsoft's
perspective this is valuable because now
we have a computer that sits on your
eyeball a very unusual situation for
human-computer interaction research so
desney town or human-computer
interaction person benefit
from this collaboration now University
of Washington benefits from this
collaboration because they get to build
one of these contact lenses and tests
the proof of principle of their research
and so together we're advancing the
state-of-the-art further than either of
us could on their own we both gain new
opportunities through this collaboration
so I said I wouldn't talk about this and
I have talked about it too much so I'll
just move on to another one but we have
plenty of other examples of this one I'm
involved in right now is a way of
looking at drug clinical trials clinical
trials are very expensive they take a
long time to run and they require a lot
of dedicated staff to produce all of the
the forms and the databases and the
questionnaires and you know protect the
privacy of all of the patients all of
that and that's a big computing load on
every on every clinical trial we have a
system that we've developed in
conjunction with the University of
Oxford that reduces that from being a
whole staff of programmers for six
months to generate that information now
we can do it with one person in two days
so when we can do that we can reduce the
cost of a clinical trial and now it's
actually cost effective to test more
drugs in the field more quickly than
before and because there's a whole
semantic layer underneath that if you
saw Evelyn VA gasps took this morning
you'll know that Microsoft is heavily
involved in semantic computing as well
because there are semantics underneath
any clinical trial generated by this
method the data set is interoperable
with any other clinical trial generated
by this data set so now instead of each
clinical trial being a single customer
example of collecting data they all feed
into the same underlying body of data
which continuously grows over time and
provides more value to the medical
community so that's the second example I
said I wouldn't talk much about that and
I did I'm sorry now I'm going to talk
about mbf and the rest of the talk is
all about the Microsoft biology
foundation so we're now on topic mbf is
an example of one of those software
developments I was talking about so we
work in producing these collaborations
that's one side of what we do the others
is a software development side and mbf
is very simple and the principle behind
it is very simple it's a bioinformatics
toolkit it's a set of common functions
that people can use to manipulate DNA
RNA and protein that's the basic
building blocks of the rest of biology
basically and the reason why we built a
library of these functions is because
we're just starting to move into the
biological field and so we choose them
chose the most basic building blocks of
biology as the place to start so that's
that's what we did essentially what mbf
does is it provides you with only three
or four different types of function you
can read files own biological formats
you can write files in biological
formats that it has a bunch of
biological algorithms built into it for
the manipulation comparison and and
other types of changes to DNA RNA and
protein sequences and it also connects
to web services microsoft clearly attic
biology so if you're studying pathways
or metabolic flux analysis or
biodiversity all of these things are
relevant to you for example for
biodiversity as I think probably the
audience knows better than I do very
often DNA sequencing is the only way to
determine the differences between
closely related species of insect for
example because the phenotypic variation
is so so limited or you might want to
look at metagenomics and actually study
the microbiological component of the
ecosystems that you're looking at in
which case you would pick a different
set of techniques but again it boils
down to DNA sequencing we do provide
here an alternative to other biology
frameworks we know that the there are
there are other types of biology
framework out there bioperl bio Java
biopython and others and they've been
around longer than us and they they have
a considerably largest selection of
functions that they perform however what
we found in in bioinformatics is there
are many many different file formats for
a
example because scientists like to
define new file formats all the time it
seems but only a few of them are used
regularly and so we to a certain extent
starting late or coming late into
bioinformatics has provided us with an
advantage because many of the different
file formats that have been generated
tried and discarded in the past we
simply don't use there are very few file
formats which everybody uses and we make
sure mbf handles those formats and
handles them very well the other thing
that we do well as we handle large
datasets when we were going to genomics
institutes and finding out how they work
to collect information to build mdf what
we found is that a lot of the time the
tools that worked very well five or six
years ago in this field are no longer
capable of handling the very large
amounts of data that are now available
somebody was giving me an example of how
they they run a tool that they've been
using for many years and now it takes
three or four days simply to load the
data into that computer computational
program that it used to take them you
know ten minutes when they first started
out so things aren't scaling very well
here and so we spent a lot of time
thinking about this problem and figuring
out how we handle very large data sets a
couple of examples of the way that we do
it inside NBF one of them is that if
your DNA sequence if you're interested
in only variations in a DNA sequence and
not the whole sequence then we have a
sparse sequence model which enables us
to store only those variations and not
the sequence now it's completely
transparent to the user you don't
realize that the the computer is only
manipulating a small set of data rather
than the large data set you fed it but
nonetheless it's it's one way of
improving the efficiency of that of the
whole system a second way is we know
that a lot of biological data exists in
extremely large files i just downloaded
one on my laptop today and it's 960
megabytes and and that's compressed and
that's one of five or six of those files
that i have to download it's actually
the smallest one of the set so
biological data sets are growing all the
time they're already very large what we
do in NBF is
we actually have a virtualization layer
built underneath all of our algorithms
so that instead of reading the whole
file in in one go we actually take a
chunk of that file read it in and then
page other chunks in and out of memory
as you walk through the file so that
you're never actually load all the data
and that way again it can be more
efficient and there are other types of
efficiency we've been building into the
algorithms as we go and Michael be
showing you some examples of how those
efficiencies are actually improving the
performance of mbf later on in this talk
the design goals of mbf we wanted it to
be extensible Microsoft might be
building might've built and VF initially
but the purpose here is to make sure is
to build a community around mbf to get
other people to make contributions we
can't possibly build NBF to satisfy all
of your scientific needs we'd be doing
it for decades we'd never be finished
one thing about biology is even if you
have a room full of biologists who are
working in the same biological area
they'll all be working on different
aspects of the problem they all require
different programs if you look at the
scientific way of that the number of
scientific computing programs available
out there for biology there's a huge
number each one of those programs only
has a very small number of users because
it's only appropriate for a very small
area of biology Microsoft can't possibly
build the thousands and thousands of
tools that you all need so what what
we've done instead is we've built a core
a core of those common components and
that's mbf but we look to the community
to extend it to meet their own
individual needs and we've made it easy
to extend and that's the extensibility
piece and I can talk more about that
later language neutrality not everybody
programs in c-sharp it's a shame I think
personally everybody should program in C
sharp but if you wish to use other other
programming languages the advantage of
building NBF on top of the dotnet
platform is that dotnet supports over 70
different languages so if you're
familiar with Pascal or you you like to
use visual basic or if you want to use a
functional programming language like F
sharp all of these are supported you can
write in any of those things and you can
use em behalf natively is if
written in the language that you're
using and you can contribute to mbf in
any of those languages and extend the
functionality so you're not tied down to
using one particular language the other
thing is we've tried as best we could to
ensure that the way in which mbf is
written is also a lesson to how to write
good code because biologists aren't
necessarily programmers so you know when
I was learning when I was a biologist I
didn't pick up a book and read about a
programming language it's boring I
didn't want to do that I wanted to do my
job so what i did is i downloaded code
from the net and I looked at house are
other people had done similar things and
then I hacked that code until it did
what I wanted it to do and I expect most
of the people in this room especially if
you're familiar with using Perl or
Python or Java you're probably familiar
with doing that kind of thing it's
basically how bioinformaticians work so
what we did is we made sure that our
code examples are extremely well
documented there's documentation in the
code so you don't have to spend your
time hacking around in great detail to
try and make something work because you
can read how it works in the code it's
an example of the best practices of how
you would use C sharp in your
application so it's also a lesson in
itself it's an education just to read
the code of mbf and that's by design now
not only that but we've implemented
basic algorithms algorithms you can read
in the literature smith-waterman
Needleman bunch of things like that and
where every time we've implemented one
of those algorithms in mb f we've
included the literature reference in the
code as well and so we're not doing
anything to in secret if you want to
know how we're doing pairwise comparison
you can go read the reference and that's
exactly what we implemented so you'll
learn from that as well we've also
developed training course materials
available under the creative commons
license so that anybody can take those
training materials they include work two
examples of the workshops so that you
can actually write code on your on your
machine as you follow along they're all
available online because their creative
commons you can download them you can
edit them you can manipulate them in any
way you like and they actually form the
good a good basis for an entire
bioinformatics curriculum and of course
you have mb F&M BF is available under
the apache 2.0 open sore
license so again you can offer that to
students as well so I'm just really
making a point here that I've made
before mbf is not an application in
itself if you download mb f you can't
run mdf it's not an it's not a program
that you can run mb f is a basic layer
of functions and you have to build tools
on top of it now we offer some of those
tools we actually offer some demo tools
that allow you to assemble DNA sequence
to do comparative a multiple sequence
alignment for example to use some
visualization so that you can see
interesting associations between the
sequence of of interest and the blast
hits that are returned from NCBI for
example all of these things they're not
intended to be fully functional
applications in their own right although
no doubt some biologists will find them
useful but they have been built in a way
many of them are open source you can
download the source and you can extend
them to meet your exact needs so I'll
skip that this is something I often get
asked so I'm just going to cover it here
we're Microsoft we'd like you to see the
benefit in using Microsoft tools but i'm
not here to sell you a copy of sequel
server we're in microsoft research we're
very fortunate in that the people that
we work with and the reason why we work
with those people it's all about the
scientific research not about selling
copies of our of our products but we
want you to see the value in using
microsoft technologies for your science
but the science comes first and if you
need to use a different platform that's
possible so what we do here is mbf uses
dotnet as its as its platform but
there's a public domain version of
dotnet called mono and mono is
implemented in such a way that it runs
on linux and it runs on OS OS x so you
can use it on a mac so what you can do
is you can actually take NBF and you can
run it on a mac or on a linux machine if
you want to now i don't guarantee it'll
run perfectly on a mac or linux machine
we don't test it extensively in those
environments and probably you'll find
that it's faster and more flexible if
you're if you're running it on a Windows
machine
but nonetheless this is an option that's
open to you just in the same way as we
pars a huge variety of file formats and
we build API so you can build pauses for
whatever files you want just in the same
way as we connect to web services so
that you can access data set which
aren't accessible to us perhaps even
aren't on the Microsoft platform
somewhere there interoperability is not
just a good idea we need to be
interoperable to survive in the
scientific community and mbf is
interoperable so don't think that you
just forced to use Microsoft all the way
although if anybody would like to buy a
copy of sequel server please come and
see me at the end okay so I've talked
about mbf being open I've talked about
it being open source and the last real
step here that I should talk about is
that it needs to be a part of the
community we need your help because we
can't build everything we need and so
what we're doing is we we've made it
available for commercial and academic
use free of charge under the apache two
point O license so anybody can obtain it
the installers are available as you'll
see from that URL there and the source
code is available from codeplex now
codeplex if you're familiar with
sourceforge you're familiar with
codeplex it's a repository of open
source code so you can go there you can
you can download the the source and you
can do anything you like with it but
more than that we're building a
community around this so we're offering
training courses free of charge we're
putting those training courses videos on
the web we've got a set of forums if you
go to mbf codeplex com you can actually
submit questions and the development
team will answer them if you find bugs
you can submit bugs and the development
team will fix them if they have the time
and of course you can become
contributors and if mbf doesn't do what
you need it to do please write write the
extension that you need send it back to
us and we will integrate it into the
code and make it available in the next
mbf release and it will again be under
the apache two point O license so you're
not giving something to Microsoft
particularly you're actually
contributing it to a growing mbf
community the other thing I should say
is the NPF project is not guided by
Microsoft alone since the beginning of
the project we've been guided by
technical advisory board in which
Microsoft is a member
we also have other adopters of mdf on
that board we've got the University of
Texas at Austin we've got queensland
university of technology we've got
Cornell we've got aluminum Corporation
manufacturers of additive one of the
most well-known DNA sequencing
instruments and we've got Johnson &
Johnson pharmaceutical research and
development so we have an excellent
mixture of commercial and academic
adopters actually steering this project
into the future we don't say what goes
into mbf next they do the community says
what goes into NBF next and the last
thing here might come as a surprise to
you mbf will not be owned by microsoft
microsoft has built it most of it to
data we've been responsible for most of
that but as soon as version 2 is
released in july one of the
announcements which will occur when we
were when we release is that Microsoft
is given up ownership of MDF and we've
transferred it to the outer curve
foundation now the outer curve
foundation logo is here and actually
outer curve is similar to the Apache
foundation if you're familiar with the
open source community it's basically it
is a it is an entity that exists to own
software projects and because they own
it we no longer own it we want to be
contributors to the community Microsoft
wants to help build MDF we need to see
it as a success in the future our own
internal Microsoft researchers are using
MDF in their own research and they will
be making contributions into mbf in the
future but what we really want you to do
and if you don't take anything else away
from this talk please take this one
thing we would like you to become
contributors to it and to extend it
yourselves to make it useful to you and
to contribute also to the community and
make this a success so thank you very
much I'd like to introduce you to
Michael is this kowski who will now give
you the second part of it our talk cool
thanks Simon you guys can hear me okay
it's very awesome thank you sir ok so
I'm a program manager on this project
and quick background we're almost
through the second year of effort on on
the Microsoft biology
foundation and bf I'll talk briefly
about what happened in the first
iteration of the project but most of the
rest of the talk and I promise to you
guys out of here in time for lunch will
be about what's happened the later part
of this year and what the advancements
are in the software library that you can
expect in July ok recapping and I'm
going to go pretty quickly through some
of these slides to make sure that we get
out on time but a lot of this is what
Simon already mentioned we're going to
support support the genomics domain from
the sequencing machine up into an fully
annotated genome and that's the scope of
of the effort to date again any library
contributions and any further domain
interest rather proteomics or other
areas of functional genomics it's all
it's all possible but this is the area
that we're focusing on to give a really
solid foundation to the library and
allow it room to grow we found that the
customers the researchers in this space
really vary widely in their expertise
from the biology through the computer
science you know bioinformatics is a
relatively young discipline and so we've
we've tried to we've tried to be as
complete as possible in all of the
documentation in the coding styles in
the code comments and make it as easy as
we could for the novice computer
programmer to come up to speed quickly
so if you're an advanced computer
science programmer and you've been
around a while and you'll find it a
piece of cake but we really wanted to go
for the least common denominator of the
types of people who would likely be
trying to use the software and we also
you know the tools side of the equation
are also pretty important because it's
really hard to express the value of a
software library without showing what it
can do so we have put some effort into
some of the tools and in doing so we've
tried to
got some of the more interesting or
common scenarios that the biologists and
the violin fermentations are doing in
this space and and give give a good view
of what the library is capable of doing
in this regard and so this is this is
also part of our audience is the actual
biologists who are using tools that are
built on top of this platform so whether
you're more in the computer science side
or more on the biology side I hope that
I can address all your needs ok so high
level Microsoft biology foundation
consists of an object model which is
essentially the representation of
genomic sequence data on top of that
you've got more of the functional
components of the library including you
know file parsers and for matters this
is how you get your data in and out of
the object model the algorithms that
allow you to do alignments assembly you
can do transcriptomes or transcription
sorry and then the web service
interfaces on top of that stack then
you'll have the tool sets and we're
providing a couple pretty compelling
examples I think of how the library can
be integrated with Excel and we have a
self-contained application called a
sequence assembler it's written in
dotnet and WPF and it shows some of the
visualization capabilities that you can
get by integrating different Microsoft
technologies together and then some
command line tools which are really just
simple samples functional programming
tools for leveraging the capabilities
inside the library okay getting a little
bit deeper now these are the namespaces
we're currently using inside the library
the base name we start with is bio and
this is again kind of matches to the to
the object model I showed on the
previous slide and we have the concept
of sequences DNA RNA proteins the
different alphabets right ambiguity
characters are supported we also have a
single single nucleotide polymorphism
representation inside the library
base level highly efficient data
structures which is a really important
thing when you're dealing with very
large sequence data memory consumption
is a critical factor in maintaining
performance and the ability to operate
on large sequences the i/o portion these
are the set of file format extensions
that are currently supported in the
library if you're familiar with these
they'll make sense if not they're
basically the the most commonly used
formats for sequence representation and
you know there's a whole bunch of
different ones so in addition to picking
what we heard from the community as the
most widely used we also made it very
easy to extend the format and add any
other types of file format supports that
you might need the one in italics at the
bottom has actually been added for
version two we were focusing more on
annotation support for the next release
of mbf and and this is part of that
effort the algorithms we started with
alignment algorithms these were kind of
we found that the base need of most
researchers in this field smith-waterman
Needleman bunch we have implemented
mummer and newcomer which are pretty
widely used alignment tools and then MSA
is a multiple sequence alignment novel
approach based off of a few other
algorithms in the industry but done by a
researcher that we had from Carnegie
Mellon University and he wrote a paper
and published that and so we have in
addition to doing the industry standard
sort of implementation of algorithms
we're also applying some new techniques
that we think could could improve the
capacity quality and performance of
alignments assembly de novo assembly is
used to piece together DNA reads into a
contiguous sequence without an owner
Prince and this was something that was
implemented in the v1 effort for mbf
since that time we've made great strides
in increasing the capacity capability of
the library when the first version came
out we really took a breath approach and
and our motto was we're going to
reinvent the wheel so you don't have to
try to give base amount of functionality
that had some degree of parity with the
bio Perl and bio Java libraries that are
available but we didn't go very deep and
we didn't scale very well and so the
biggest effort the largest effort that
we're taking in the current
implementation of the library is to
increase the capacity and the
performance and the scalability of the
library so the dinovo assembler has has
come a long way and i'll show some
numbers here in a few minutes
comparative assembly is a new feature
inside the library and this is the
concept here is is that well actually
I'll to address that in a second and
then web services primarily the ones
we've implemented our against blass
different blast services but again the
framework supports easy extensibility to
all sorts of different web service
connectors okay so Assembly of large
genomes I think I mentioned this one
that's our top goal right now we're also
focusing more on the annotation side so
being able to read different formats of
data that contain annotations allow user
annotations and support and tools that
also provide for some visualization
capabilities and I'll do a quick demo we
also want to make sure that the
developer experience is very good so
debugging is easy easy to create and
extend new parsers algorithms well
documented and easy to build tools on
top of as well I guess the other thing I
should say about the developer piece is
one of the things that we've found it by
using the.net framework for is how
it is to paralyze algorithms that lend
themselves to parallelization via the
dotnet parallel extensions and we've
made extensive use of that and
especially in our assembly and alignment
algorithms and we think that's also
something that people are going to
appreciate and community is the big one
so this is really Microsoft is in this
just to get it going we really want this
to be a community-owned and lead effort
it's it's really up to the to the to the
community to decide how widely this is
adopted and used and how it expands and
we're going to continue supporting the
community but we're we're we're very
adamant that that's the direction this
is going okay so one of the techniques
we use at Microsoft when we do software
development is we identify scenarios
that are core to what the software
experience should provide at the end
this helps define and scope our effort
it also helps us know when we're
successful and it keeps us focused along
the way so our core scenario that we
chose to help address the primary goal
of supporting large genomes in this
effort was taking some example polyploid
genomes agricultural genomes and making
sure that we can assemble those and it's
one of the reasons that we've
implemented the comparative assembly
techniques that I'll show you some
details on in a minute lots of different
ways that being able to assemble
sequences of this nature can benefit
society we have an internal science team
at Microsoft Research and led by a man
named David heck erman Rick rash had
briefly mentioned him in his opening
keynote and kind of skipped over a few
things but he's pretty well known in the
field and well in the software
development field for using machine
learning to create the spam filter and
Microsoft Outlook well he also happens
to be a
PhD MD and is now applying those machine
learning techniques towards the analysis
of HIV and and so he's he's an internal
customer microsoft that we have very
close access to that's well connected
with the rest of the bio informatics
community but also provides us with a
really valuable scenario with data
access and the expertise to tell us if
it's working or not so we work closely
with with david and his team we align
our goals against the scenario and you
know our key deliverables are to make
sure that we actually support the
Assembly of large genome so that it can
be leveraged in other ways and then also
the analysis tools that can be used by
the scientist to evaluate how things
came out and do annotations and there's
some pretty cool things that can be done
using deep zoom and some other things
that you might have seen earlier okay so
de novo assembly I'm going to assume
most people understand what that is it's
been around for a while the comparative
assembly process I'm going to show it in
detail on the next slide the the point
here is that you know reads come off a
sequencing machine and then the reads
are they have some filtering done on
them made sure to make sure there's
there's good information you throw out
the bad reads and then you you can bring
them into the library and start working
with the data and you have to reassemble
all these reads back into what is
contiguous sequence of DNA and then you
can start figuring out well what is this
person like and then that part happens
at the end so this is a busy slide and
I'll try to walk through it quickly
there's a data preparation step at the
beginning that's what I mentioned a
second ago and that's something that the
that's outside of what mbf can manage
right now that's something that happens
click more close to the to the sequencer
different sequencers have different
filtering requirements they have
different error rates they use different
chemical processing or image processing
to generate the reeds and so it's very
specific part of the process is very
specific to what the instrumentation is
that you're using
collect DNA information but after that
it gets it gets pre the workflow is
pretty common across most bioinformatics
problems we have and what you see here
in the boxes are the command line
utilities that are provided with the NBF
platform and it's a way to exercise the
library to support this workflow the
padena util padena is the name we gave
the de novo assembler inside mbf it's
the parallelized de novo assembler so it
uses the dotnet parallel extensions to
make efficient use of all the cores
inside your machine and I won't go into
too much detail here but for the
comparative side it's it's a pretty
interesting technique and essentially
the idea is is that you're you're
reading the you're taking the reeds and
but you're using a reference it's not de
novo which means against no reference
but you're actually using a reference
genome that's a similar a similar
species so if you're trying to sequence
a genome that hasn't been sequenced
before you don't have an exact reference
but you might have something that is
closely related that's perhaps mutated
over time via evolution or maybe short
spans of evolution but you're able to
use that as a reference to help guide
the rest of the assembly process and the
tools used you know there's a whole
sequence of steps that happen and we
provide one tool called compare util
that actually will do the whole thing
for you but we've also dumb it provided
atomic unit operations so that
researchers can perform one step
evaluate results become comfortable with
what it's doing maybe make changes to
the code or maybe make changes to the
parameters that go into that algorithm
but we try to make it as easy as
possible for people to use in whatever
steps and sequence of events that they
need so a realignment happens there's
some optional steps where if you have
paired end read information you can
actually optimize or you can
optimized some of the matching
information inside the read alignments
and then there's a consensus generation
step that happens and there's a separate
utility for that and then the scaffold
generation which actually puts together
the various contigs of sequences and
aligns them against well what is assumed
to be the final DNA strand but the only
step that uses the reference sequence is
the first one and then the rest of it is
all done against itself so it's a really
interesting process and relatively novel
and we're still we're actually we've
released a beta Simon mentioned we're
going to release the final library in
July and I have some kind of hot off the
press numbers that I'll show quickly but
they will change by the time we go out
the door one of the things that we've
been doing is we've been using the
e.coli mg1655 DNA sequences a really
good benchmark there's a lot published
on this genome and I realize it's not
large but we have a lot of information
that we can compare how the NBF library
behaves against other other libraries
that are out there and I think this is
an area that you know I get a lot of
questions about so we've got a native
implementation of mummer on windows on
the same machine we're running what
we're we call this our super desktop
it's a 24 core windows 7 machine 64-bit
with 196 mega sorry that should be
gigabytes that's an error 196 gigabytes
of RAM so it's a big machine but it
wasn't really that expensive and it
wasn't really that hard for us to find
and when we talked to the labs that do
DNA sequencing this was actually a
mid-range machine that they typically
use so we feel pretty good about the
configuration that we're using to test
these things and and these on the bottom
scale here that is the coverage
reads against the genome if you're
familiar with that or if you're not
familiar with that that's the the
oversampling basically that you have on
a specific sequence of reads to help you
identify either errors in the reeds or
where you have gaps in alignment and the
higher level of coverage basically means
you have a better chance at assembling a
genome together with the data sizes also
go up dramatically so basically what
we're seeing here is a really good
improvement in terms of the mum util
tool in mbf written in you know the
dotnet language against a native
implementation of mummer in Windows and
especially as the data sizes go up the
NBF library scales very well against a
native implementation mainly because
this is a single threaded implementation
and the use of parallel extensions in
mbf library scale well across the twenty
four cores on the machine so a total
transparency but it shows the value of
what the library can provide we're also
working closely with Simon said multiple
people in the community but Cornell
University has also been doing a lot of
benchmark analysis on their own and we
were happy to see that from our v1
release of the library to our V to
release on the same e.coli stranded I
just sent you they saw a pretty
significant improvement in time to
process that genome as well and this
data was on the beta release of MV f so
you guys can download it yourself and
try this yourself and validate ah that's
a mess ok I will probably just skip this
slide this is the and you know out this
is apples to oranges anyway I tried to
you know be be local in my use of
analogies but this is a this is a
benchmark paper that we are going to be
using and we will be publishing our or
the NBF results against
the benchmark analysis here done with
different de novo assemblers right now
we're looking really good you can't
really see the numbers but I think the
main point is is that that we're being
we're trying to be very upfront with
well how does this how does the
capabilities inside this library stack
up against the other things and the
other tools that you might already be
using ok we've got a couple other I
mentioned the HIV work that David
Harriman and his team is doing the nice
thing about this collaboration is that
they they're a little bit ahead of us in
terms of the advanced research
techniques they're doing and so when
they find and identify some useful
nuggets then we'll pull those into the
library and one of those is this biology
matrix class and they've also got a
distributed computing library that
they've been working with for a while
that we're also going to provide in the
library now for more general use so
it'll be easy to not only paralyze your
applications across cores but you'll
also have a really easy framework to use
on HPC clusters and possibly going up to
as you're as well I'm gonna skip over
this this talks about the bio matrix
specifics the community challenge you
know we've talked about a lot already
the key thing here is that we're going
to facilitate responses to community
requests we're going to invest in
people's education about the library we
just held a two-day workshop over at the
Santa Clara hotel this week on Monday
and Tuesday very well attended and had a
lot of good questions and answers there
and it's an open source project through
and through its free we're not trying to
sell anything we're not we're stepping
really out of the leaders seat and and
we're generating the leadership from
inside the community of people who find
this valuable and we want to continue
fostering that and I and I hope and I'll
reiterate what Simon said anybody in the
room who's interested in this at all and
finds any value in this at all please
let us know let the community know get
involved in any way that you think
you think could be valuable and the name
is going to change but for now it's
still mbf codeplex com and that's the
best place to start a few closing
remarks we're also working closely with
the Colombian government and cleanse eos
on this bio informatics computing center
we're really excited about about what
they're doing in this space and we think
that the NBF library and as well as some
other microsoft technologies can really
help them get off the ground and we've
made a commitment to help them do this
and and I expect that they will also
become leaders and and future drivers of
where this platform goes because the
more people are leveraging it the more
vested interests they're going to have
in and where it where it leads and I
think that's great surging to the cloud
is another opportunity we've worked with
another team at Microsoft on this thing
called Azure blast and it's essentially
hosting the blast databases and the
blast query search engine integer and
unable to you know scale across multiple
nodes in order to quick efficient blast
queries and it's something that can be
hosted locally or I'm sorry that or it
could be hosted locally but in the cloud
and then also offered as a service so
the future of by informatics and where I
see I think this center going in stages
is really you know supporting research
developing tools that are needed to
solve hard research problems leveraging
cloud-based resources and then making
services available to others and you
know that progression of things is a
real natural one and I think can can can
benefit Latin America in particular
there's a few tools I was going to show
a demo and and I will if anybody wants
to to stick around but I think the last
thing I want to end on is letting you
know that there's also a contest that's
been announced and it's really easy all
you have to do is is use mbf and
tool and that does whatever it is that
you would need to do in your work and it
doesn't have to be fancy and it doesn't
have to be big it can be as simple and
efficient as you like but we're we're
hosting this now it's it's open until
July fifteenth so there's still plenty
of time and the winner gets an xbox and
a connect and then you can either play
games or you can start doing some crazy
augmented reality stuff like the guide
that's from this morning but I guess
with that if you have any other
questions I'll come back to this in a
minute but I want to give people a
chance to go to lunch and have any
questions I'm happy to answer those as
well thanks thanks sure
thank you yes two brief questions that
the first one is that in the first part
of the of the talk someone talked about
them one of the uses of microsoft
research or microsoft connection is the
work on the building of biological
computational models of biological
phenomena but it's clear that mb f is
focused on DNA RNA and protein sequences
and analysis and so it is not integrate
amin they are other any plans of
integrating or better what is they what
is the how is microsoft working and
building of applications or is there any
framework in the part of modeling
biological phenomena and the second one
that is out of just out of curiosity why
not supporting from the very beginning
of mb f the MPL format well they want me
to get that okay to answer your second
part first if you'd like file format
supported by and bf you'll be very
pleased to know that you could you two
could become a member of our community
and provide that support unfortunately
that's going to be the answer to a lot
of questions that we in terms of the
functionality the NBF has we provided a
starter set of functionality which
relates to the scenarios that Mike was
showing the ones that we've been
particularly targeted but we don't
pretend that this is a comprehensive
coverage of everything you could do and
so what we've done is we provided the
api's and the documentation that enables
people to extend the library themselves
if you do extend it to cover that
particular file format please contribute
it back and then we can incorporate it
and make it available for everyone but
that's pretty much how it has to go
because we can't satisfy everybody now
in terms of the the modeling work the
modeling work actually is mostly
occurring in Microsoft Research
Cambridge and they started many years
before mbf and so there is no direct
link between the two at
moment I talked about that more as an
example of one of the many projects that
we're doing rather than related
specifically to am BF now the modeling
platform that I'm most familiar with
that they that they offer is called spin
SP IM the stochastic pi machine it's
downloadable from Microsoft Research
Cambridge and the second one that's
based on a similar system is called
blanks ble NX and that is available from
from the University of Toronto Santa
that I mentioned you can find links
through the Microsoft Research Cambridge
site these are tools that exist rather
than NBF which is a library of functions
so it's not necessarily possible to get
into it and program it yourself but it
will run you know there's a simple
modeling language you can follow and
then you can use this to run your model
okay designs your question
just to sort of dig into that a little
more I just sort of interested to know
when inversion to when this go you know
I understand the value of this is going
to be the community contributions I'm
interested to know what what you you're
going to contribute going forward you
going to move into the proteomic space
or I me know the plans for that that was
sort of my big question most small
question is the bent art is the
benchmark data you use actually part of
the library that's downloadable I'll
take the benchmark question he'll let
you talk about next no but it's a great
idea I think we should I mean it's it's
a it's publicly available on the
internet in various places and we show
we have the links and the documentation
but I think it makes sense to include me
that associations you know I mean I
think the field is littered with cases
where people claim it's not you know one
thing or another but you can never
actually test it where I never get the
benchmark data perfect yeah that's a
great that's a great great idea i'll
take that back you'll see that myself i
should say no that's a great idea yeah i
mean just on the bench marking stuff mbf
actually comes with a set of unit tests
and the data required to support those
so in theory not quite true in practice
but almost all of the code is covered
with an extensive range of tests so that
you can show how accurate it is and the
data necessary for those tests does ship
with mbf now the benchmarking stuff you
saw here relates either to an e coli
strain that's already the subject of a
publication so I don't know whether we
would actually wish to provide it
separately but we should certainly
provide the accession number for that it
will make sure that yeah the only the
only downside is the size i thought it's
like a seven gigabyte and we're trying
to balance that but it's at least that
well and actually the benchmark metric
tool were using was provided there was
an assembly thon effort
down in California earlier this year and
that's what we're actually using to
generate the benchmark numbers as well
right and we were thinking of using the
assemblée phone data sets as well right
what was going to say they tend to come
in at about five gig each so I'm not
sure that we would want to ship those
exactly but because they are standards
only we had a diet that happens in the
community will certainly explore that
yeah on the proteomic side what do we
plan to do next well that's a very good
question what I'm glad you asked I don't
think proteomics is part of what we plan
to do next as a matter of fact but
although Microsoft is stepping away from
leading and owning the the software and
leading the community it doesn't mean we
won't stay as active contributors we
will and the several areas that we're
looking at one is the david hackman's a
science team part of microsoft research
as i said before is using the library as
part of their research there are several
different tools and technologies that
they've been producing that we're going
to absorb into the library over time
typically the way it works is David's
team produces an application and then
produces some publications based on it I
know very recently they publish them
work on using fast Fourier transform in
genome-wide Association studies that
work and other similar work will be
absorbed into the library over the
coming year so that will be able to say
that future versions of their tools will
be entirely based on NBF so that's
interesting in many ways but the
principal one that's of interest to us
is that you know you could go out and
use bio Java today instead of mbf
because we have the same functions but
in the future mbf is going to actually
be able to do things based on unique
microsoft research that no other library
has and that's where we want to get to
with that so that's one strand the
second one is although the details are
far from certain we are going to be
supporting the Columbia bioinformatics
center and we're not only going to be
providing moral support we're actually
going to providing
practical programming development effort
and one of the things that we don't on
but on Monday and Tuesday this week when
we met with the people from that Center
is we asked them to provide us with
their needs so that we actually
understand which what things we need to
implement next and we will will develop
those post version 2 and integrate those
into NBF as well so I don't exactly know
what they will be if they turn around
and say proteomics is what I need then I
guess that's what we'll be doing next
okay okay okay great um I think that's
it thank you all for coming if any i'll
let me let say one last thing on
tomorrow friday from 10 to 1 i think is
our is our demo fest and i'll go ahead
and show both gino zoom which which is a
genome browser we're going to be
providing as well as some other tools
that come along with the with the
library so please come then and all and
i'll be happy to talk more after the
event as well okay thank you